you know i mean i look at your work and
you i know you did dark angel and you
know by the way was jessica alba cool to
work with no she was horrible
are you kidding no no no she was not fun
to work with well i will tell you i've
told her i've told this to her face
really
why so what makes an actor or an actress
what makes them tough to work with i i
uh i love jess um
which i know kind of contradicts what i
just said but this is no secret you're
saying yeah no she she um she was under
an immense amount of pressure on that
show
she was young
uh she was in a
um she was in a relationship with um
one of the guys right yep and and that
was
that was rocky uh and and causing some
some undue stress i believe on set
and i was like the new
the new
fresh face on the set who wasn't really
there in season one i came in for one
episode but then they wrote me in as a
series regular for season two
and i was just kind of
i was i was the new kid on the block and
i i got i got picked on by the lead and
she
oh i mean
like
like the worst kind of bickering a
brother and sister could do
she just she had she had it out for me
she like she didn't like you i don't
know if it would no it wasn't that she
didn't like me she just was like oh oh
here's the pretty boy that that network
brought in for some more window dressing
because that's what we need
in front of the whole crew yeah
and you just kind of just well very
quickly i was like
what the [ __ ]
like what
what did i do his ass yeah so very
quickly i was just like well
fire with fire
so you fought back so i just was like oh
looks like we're getting [ __ ] alba
today
really everybody hang on to your hang
under your nuts and the crew loved it oh
loved it and she kinda did she liked it
and well it just then she was like okay
well now i can now i can just
be a dick to him and he'll be addicted
to me and that's how we'll roll
that's amazing and and it and it did it
did build some mutual respect
so you got along as the time when you
know she was under a lot of pressure you
know she was kind of [ __ ] at times
yeah and eventually you kind of accepted
it but she kind of got okay touche two
shades just
but we but we bickered we bickered like
brother and sister but then like you
know there were moments
uh uh
you know when uh when her guy was away
she didn't like to
she was like scared of this house that
they were running and so she asked me to
come over and just keep her company oh
so i did provocative that's well
i guess it could have been but i just
knew i was like no this is very this is
very platonic very brother sister jesus
but then like uh got me over her house
to keep her company yeah no trust me
looking back i i shake my head at like
jesus did i miss something there yeah
was i
just tone deaf like hey pretty boy in a
nightgown
hey pretty boy
no she would have kicked me the nuts if
i tried anything right um
which she if she was she's very very
tough little uh um woman little vixen
vixen yeah uh but again like my
grandfather died while i was shooting
and she literally just walked into my
trailer and just held me for you know
half an hour all right so so there there
was it was that kind of a relationship
right and again if you know she walked
in we'd be all hugs right but but it was
she didn't make it easy
on me do you remember going back home
after set after a long day and talking
to one of your buddies going damn man
she gives me such [ __ ] hell yeah i was
like i feel like i'm getting bullied
here were you nervous at all will it
make you kind of like like [ __ ] the lead
doesn't like me she's gonna get me fired
no because i forget who it was but a
friend of mine was like
um
it was like
what did he say it gave me kind of some
sort of a confidence booster of like
well she's intimidated by you or she
likes you
or she likes you or something which i
mean i just told myself that just to
kind of give me the confidence that i
needed to kind of get through the day
right but uh
unfortunately it only went one more
season and that was that